I punched Ryan Reynolds in the face by
accident yeah that didn't feel good no
so there's a scene where it's Ryan and
Sam and Selma and we have them uh tied
up their hands behind their back and I'm
coming in to interrogate him I'm from
bomb the detective and I got he's he's
doing his thing where he yaps you know
and I punch him in the face right so I
take a swing and goes girl do not punch
me in the face I go brother I've been
boxing since I'm 11. I'm not gonna punch
in the face just don't lean in
First Take
I clip him right
like not all contact but a little
contact I hit him you grazed him I hit
him yeah I hit him and he's and did you
Brian Glazer him yes or was it no no no
no I graze him any and but that's the
thing that they kept in the uh was he
pissed no no he was a good sport about